24 seconds of logo
why did Harry and Dumbledore wait around
at the ministry after the big fight with
Voldemort for the dozens of news crews
to show up especially if he's gonna be
ushering him away from the press like he
doesn't want Harry to go through that
pressure I mean damn hmm storm clouds in
London better go to the window to
witness this extremely rare occurrence
these three smoke monster guys destroy a
bridge that everyone conveniently runs
off before it sinks into the water
Harry Potter is Harry Potter why is
Harry reading the magic newspaper
containing moving pictures in a non
magic public ass place that's the guy I
saw picture me that's what I'm saying
hey I was wondering Levin listen I get
off damn that's specific billboard irony
well well if it isn't that long blocker
Dumbledore wanting to talk to Harry
after spending the entire previous year
not talking to Harry the tale is
thrilling if I say so myself but now is
not the time to publish because reasons
actually said all these years I just
sort of go with it you go with it
despite the fact that no one has ever
taken you to the Hubble puffs to stick
your Slytherin in someone's Gryffindor
ansan huh oh wait maybe I underestimated
Dumbledore blood drips from the ceiling
to let character know to look up cliche
blood tasty come on did this guy really
not know his feet were sticking out of
the chair also how did licking the blood
drop from Harry's head tell Dumbledore
moon better give that chair a closer
look anyway over the week then now to
Dumbledore know where to fucking forget
it even more impressive when one
considers she was about goalball that's
racist one of my best friend's is
muggle-born
she's the best in our year and yet you
keep getting all the credit my absolute
favorites just a minute ago you said
those who own this place are in the
Canary Islands but now we're supposed to
believe that you have pictures of all
the people who are important to you one
of them just happening to be harry's mom
sitting here in this muggle house also
you said I never say any wave over the
week so that means you're carrying
around 19 framed pictures to a new place
every week no doubt no these older
brother Sirius died a few weeks ago
Harry's in the news everywhere because
of the show down at the Ministry of
Magic which is where Sirius died so how
to slow Horn know that Sirius died but
not know that Harry was there when it
happened Professor Slughorn
and that's all I need to say about that
that's why he's returning to Hogwarts
and it's crucial he should return but I
won't tell you why until much much later
if at all I fear I may have stolen a
wondrous night from you Harry magical
cock-blocking Dumbledore is a dick is
there ever a time when this pan isn't
getting magically scrubbed in the sink
hey breakable franchise waits until the
sixth movie to mention the unbreakable
vow thing which is no doubt super
important but not really also with an
unbreakable vow exists and is so
powerful why not use it to do something
impossible
like I vow to impress Kate Upton with my
considerable math skills
if carry out movie is jumping up and
down trying to tell you everything about
the ending right here in the first 20
minutes which makes you wonder why they
bothered with the other two hours and 10
minutes but whatever or shadowing you
are amazed how did the glowing magic
wrist thing know that this was the end
of all the vows dick schaap hey let's go
into the bombed-out former wand store so
the plot can happen brilliant isn't Leo
D Drake - a mummy - about to pay for you
don't want to be fired okay first of all
Draco would clearly have seen you
assholes since you literally just walked
into this place from the same street
before saying this and second are there
people who want to be followed also does
every single plot point in the Harry
Potter universe hinge on someone
overhearing something or being in the
right place to see something at the
right time also why do the Malfoy's walk
to this super secret meeting place out
in the open where anyone can see where
they're going don't they have the
ability to magically transport like
we've seen all the good guys do in this
series I'm just saying if I had been
Baltimore in this series I would have
won city planners made it amazingly easy
to eavesdrop on people no matter where
they go in their own house how do they
get up there on oh never mind you think
that would be one of the first tasks
when calling a secret meeting shoulder
troll what's the rocks butt
the invisible creatures they float in
your ears and make your brain go fuzzy
oh cool what so what was draco dome
without weird-looking cabinet and who
were all those people and why did I wait
all the way until now to ask these
questions
it happened he's one of them pronoun
game best excuse for school people Harry
Potter is right
apparently Malfoy can just stay on the
train with a whole car to himself
without anyone noticing or caring why is
Luna still on the damn train you've got
to be kidding me with this thankfully
Luna also just happens to be wearing
super secret 3d magic glasses that allow
her to find Harry how'd you know where I
was yeah but you didn't notice that
until you walked into this car for
absolutely no explained reason why is
Haley's nose still bleeding didn't
Malfoy we kick him like an hour ago
then Luna fixed his nose and now he
comes in with this thing like it just
happened or something since when does
the Sorting Hat have important things to
say and do anything other than tell
people what house they go to and here's
where I point out the avalanche of
convenience that leads Harry to the
half-blood Prince's book capped off with
the oh so clever one old book one new
book standoff with Ron King Bravo you
maestro's only girls are inexplicably
drawn to the love potion all they want
to do is get married and have kids they
should in fact just drop out now and
find a husband before they turn into old
mates
desperately tricky to make disastrous
should you get it wrong but there is a
way to make it so why aren't there
gallons of this and let's say in
Baltimore had some of it and Dumbledore
had some of it but with the luck potion
favored then once it could you will find
that all of your endeavors succeed my
only question is the Kevin we heard
about this potion or seen it used dozens
of times already during the trials and
tribulations these assholes have endured
and don't give you that it's tricky to
make either like this series is always
done with regular magical items
something this useful would have been
mass-produced by now crush it don't cut
it no specifically say to cut and why is
that was the book translated from
Sanskrit or something why is the
textbooks recipe wrong Dumbledore asks
Harry if he's into Hermione and then
dismisses the topic as soon as Harry
says he isn't because let's be honest
that was for you the audience and not
for anyone actually in this scene
Dumbledore's memory of his first meeting
with Tom Riddle is so vivid he remembers
a photograph of a place that just
happens to be of major importance to the
entire story
snakes - they find me is that normal for
someone like me
Dumbledore must have left out as part of
the memory where he completely and
utterly disregarded this question did I
know I just met the most dangerous Dark
Wizard of all time no but how you see
Professor Slughorn possesses something I
designed a very dirty but I'm not gonna
say what it is yet because screw you
that's why you said Professor Slughorn
will try to collect me yeah what the did
you mean by that
do you want me to let him wait you know
what the fuck we meant by that Malfoy
always has an apple on hand just in case
he needs to eat it look like even more
of an asshole
why does one team's Quidditch tryouts
have such a large spectator turnout and
why in sirmione here instead of studying
I know she likes Ron in the romantic way
but still she didn't even bring books
keepers needs to be quick that's all
it's count Daniel son think you could
introduce me to your friend Granger
wouldn't mind a getting on a first-name
basis know what I mean dude you're the
handsomest guy in all of Hogwarts you
can't work up the courage to talk to her
mining she's a little bunny and you're a
bear and you're looking at these claws
and these fangs and you're like how do I
kill the bunny okay movie shows us
Hermione looking Ron than the other
keeper try out dude who was obviously
looking back and flirting and then cuts
to the wide shot to show you how
ridiculously impossible it would be for
all that eye contact to happen okay
first of all here's the Harry Potter
universe again giving us the finger
regarding the need for wands to do magic
second of all cheating this is an awful
small sample size to judge your keepers
I mean a couple of throws decides who's
gonna be on the team shouldn't this
process be at least a week with lots and
lots of chances seen before you make
your decision she's tough blood Prince
roll credits how's about a bit no I've
been to your Wizarding World and I had
your butter beer and it's disgusting
cream soda crossed with marshmallow
across with 15 pounds of sugar you
turned sweet into a swear word it would
be welcome to Granger and Kieran good to
see you uh-huh he can't remember Ron's
name classic major plot thing happens at
the exact same time Harry and company
leave the bar none of these students
with magical powers do anything while
this girl is hovering in the air good
thing Hagrid just happens to be here why
is it when something happens
it is always you three were you not
briefed on how they were just minding
their own goddamn business I think
unless bro its lucky to be alive it's
pretty lucky that every student at
Hogwarts has survived every single
attempted murder since year one might be
because there's magic for everything my
knees feel my skin when you say as skin
goes I mean I've never really thought
about it
liar a monster existed it was buried
deep within then why did you cast such a
creepy kid to play Tom Riddle in the
Dumbledore flashback seems to me the
monster not only existed but was right
on the damn surface you get the sense
that Lunas the Lady Gaga of this group
maybe like she's just being weird for
the sake of being weird
we're in the sixth movie and Quidditch
is somehow still a big deal like
Voldemort is out there and recruiting
people and readying for war but we still
need to watch Quidditch matches in this
movie scene but it took one to love
Goods keen eyes to even bring up the
idea that you put something in his drink
earlier you didn't tell Ron about it
until she started opening up her weird
Yap
have we seen Hermione and Ron joking
with each other
touching each other any kind of clue
that they were attracted to each other
there's absolutely no chemistry between
them just because a book or a movie says
two people are gonna be together doesn't
mean the attraction was there all
Hogwarts is big enough for Harry to have
to do a bit of looking around in order
to find Hermione but small enough for
Ron and kissy pants to just straight
fight by on accident it's Ron Weasley
magic makes the human component in the
book finally largely unnecessary man is
this whole movie gonna be Love Actually
hey should be interesting you because
she thinks will the chosen one
okay hey he is and B he's only
interested in her because you just
pointed her out as a possible date
someone or some thing ate the apple and
was an asshole also why did the evil
forces need to test their magic
teleportation cabinet that obviously was
built for this very purpose also I guess
this is something that takes an entire
fucking school year to learn you know so
we can go through all the damn teen
angst this movie has to offer I know
right he's already in the Slughorn Club
he was coming here tonight regardless
just hold yourself a month's detention
McLaggen this is a private party and not
a school function and vomiting is a
month detention you gotta be shittin me
I believe it was Snape in the earlier
movie who somehow knew Harry was
eavesdropping on the teachers outside
Dumbledore's office right and said this
conversation is no longer private right
but here no idea he's being listened to
surreptitiously
move out sure that's what slope says
Harry waits until they get on the train
to discuss the thing he overheard did he
just keep this information to himself
thinking man if only we could get on a
train and I could finally discuss this
what happens if you break an unbreakable
vow I thought the very meaning of the
term was that you physically could not
break it plenty of magic to go around
during a time when everyone's scared of
a massive threat we can't protect the
children but we can't make cake toppers
dance so we got that going for us to
make an unbreakable vow these people
can't just find out from Dumbledore that
Snape's allegiance to his vow is part of
its double double-cross is there any
reason they don't have the understanding
of this that Albus does is a vanishing
cabinet a vanishing cabinet I know all
right
why haven't we ever heard of these
things before no franchise in history
gets more mileage out of making shit up
as they go along than this one does so
too badass wizard adults struggle with
the fire after Harry jumps through and
then Ginny just runs by like Lala I'm
getting me any spells you could cast a
stupefy Harry and Ginny and maybe
apparate and Harry to Baltimore
especially since you can't kill them
because of the stupid saved them for
Baltimore rule why didn't they do that
in the first place why is the family
that uses magic to scrub pans and move
cake toppers worried about a simple fire
can't they just magic up themselves a
new tree house confuse I'd be surprised
if you weren't since I've been
intentionally keeping crucial
information from you why would he temple
with his own memory yeah why stop at
tampering surely there's a spell that
could make you forget something
completely well why is it that when
someone is obviously acting strangely in
this world no one immediately thinks
curse or charm or that guy might not be
Ron at all must be Ron getting into the
liquor cabinet again
glug glug she knows I exist very well
hope so she's been stalking you for
three months okay how are you talking
about you mean Ron's been playing the
pronoun game this entire time jeez this
was a long calm version of it
fortunately for Harry Ron gets stung by
some kind of weird love potion that
gives him the perfect excuse to get back
into Slughorn's good graces I've always
found him interesting love how all the
teachers are just silently absorbing the
teen romance drama unfolding in front of
them so there aren't more important
topics to discuss or things to do Draco
has no peripheral vision or spatial
awareness whatsoever to not see Harry
right now also I know Draco has been
doing this a lot this year but what
convenient timing for him to walk by
mysteriously just as Harry is walking
alone mysteriously a reminder its path
Christmas and drink hose vanishing
cabinet experiments have only graduated
from Apple to small bird
why was the vanishing cabinet sixth on
the list of all Voldemort's potential
Hogwarts Harry defeat plants doesn't
this seem easier than several of the
previous plans he's bafflingly gone with
a head of this one now magic doesn't
even have to be done on purpose to
happen Harry uses a spell he literally
just read the name up in a book five
minutes ago without knowing what it does
LM surprised he could even pronounce it
correctly on the first try
recalling his ridiculous butchering of
Diagon Alley in the second film so even
when someone cast a spell that causes
this much blood loss there's a spell
that keeps them alive apparently harry's
allowed to just chill with his friends
after merely committing a murder
and no enquiries aren't necessary have
to get rid of it today or simply don't
use the spells out of the book that
explicitly saved four enemies on it that
would work to throne for comment
wait so after the last movie they just
stuffed this rumoured requirement full
of junk like a warehouse and not only
that but Drake was been coming here all
year to kill birds and teleport apples
but he was allowed in because he really
needed it
what's going on here he tied the
half-blood Prince's book I know will
ever find it including you when you see
parallax in this room you'll understand
why this is a bad idea
just destroy the thing like one usually
eats early takes a walk and then returns
to his office how many nights did you
stake out the marauders map to know his
schedule this fucking well Harry just
thought of a liquid luck idea like in
the last scene man if this character it
said Merlin's beard just one more time
in this movie we would have been
compelled by common sense to make a
bonus round seriously misunderstood
creatures spiders are yeah but in the
Chamber of Secrets this one in
particular was gonna kill Ron an area
before the magic car came and saved them
I think these spiders are properly
understood spider funeral also movie
over two and a half hours long has time
for the spider funeral he's drunk now so
surely he'll start spilling the secrets
Harry needs and what's a guy like me to
say about the convenience of that when
the screenplay already excused it with
liquid luck ex machina can you saw
instance in the near future this
conversation will take place about
splitting movies into seven parts and
all of our souls will be broken that day
it could be in any way true I'm assuming
that despite the fact they leave traces
you're still gonna have to kind of know
where they are and this will still not
be in any way easy too bad there isn't a
way to make some sort of liquid that
creates luck for this situation clay
thing going is Nessa and you leave the
school yes and I think perhaps I may
have found another thing what you just
said beyond anything I imagined so which
is it asshole
you wanted there hadn't imagined it or
you've been investigating it for months
forgive my mawkishness all right I'm an
old man still at the same to Mesa at
least since the third movie you must
obey every command I give you Voldemort
split his soul into seven Horcruxes but
he decided the only one of them needed
to be an RPG adventure to find well sure
I'm glad that Baltimore kept a nice
picture of this place in his orphan room
that a memory somehow remembered in
order to gain passage payment was made
how about just not making it any way
possible for any kind of passage was
Baltimore planning on coming back here
to visit his Horcrux is
question is how do we get there I don't
know apparate maybe he's calling a boat
out of the water but it's kind of hard
to believe that in a world with a spell
that makes cake toppers dance there's
not also a spell just to create a boat
and plop it right where you're standing
how about casting the Agua meant a spell
directly into his mouth or have him cut
his hands oh no I guess there are no
options other than to drink the dirty
cave water army of discount golems is
this a good time to ask whether the
Patronus charm is strictly for Dementors
couldn't it help in this situation two
seriously wanted to take this long for
the teleporting cabinet thing to work
and just in time for Dumbledore's return
from the Voldemort's soul cave in a
world full of magical bullshit that is
completely unnecessary there is
apparently nothing called an anti
eavesdropping spell they can create
invisible train station entrances fix
eyeglasses and other completely useless
like dancing kick Stoppers have I
mentioned this movie has magical dancing
cake toppers because it does do this
honestly leaving the assassination of
Draco who thought this was a good idea
so potions can turn people into other
people so why didn't break oh just stay
home while Bellatrix drank a potion and
pretended to be Drake oh she could have
ended this really quickly like on the
first day of school he doesn't have the
stomach just like his father casually
tried to kill Harry in the Chamber of
Secrets so where does this sudden idea
that Lucius doesn't have the stomach to
kill innocent people come from Avada
Kedavra
Snape is addicted Dumbledore also since
we know later that Snape and Dumbledore
planned this does Snape soul still break
into after killing him that's how I
heard it works anyway kind of a harsh
penalty to pay for an agreement like
this
no wait you mean she didn't know that
Harry was being saved for Baltimore and
why did she wait to kill him in that
wheat field earlier also if he belongs
to the Dark Lord why doesn't Bellatrix
just take Harry to him
we know my Snape won't do it but she
doesn't have any reason not to
[Music]
for a spoonful of sugar helps the
medicine go down
by grabthar's hammer water savings once
it was a young man I want some more
think you could introduce me to your
friend Granger wouldn't mind getting on
a first-name basis know what I mean a
sign of war sign them all now Tammy
nudge nudge go to your houses
[Music]
I hope that's not a hostage what if that
had been poop
that's enough for me
oh come on don't listen don't worry
about too much wine I mean I'm not gonna
let you have too much wine because you
know you know your folks may smell it on
your breath
how they might get mad at me pretty bird
yeah can you say pretty bird pretty bird
[Music]
I haven't been formed like that since
grade school